under the crisis at the southern border
as if the situation weren't bad enough
a growing number of migrants infected
with coronavirus
trying to enter the u.s simply adding to
the chaos republican senator lindsey
graham
said he's had enough and is pressing the
department of homeland security for
answers
what i'm asking the the homeland
security secretary to do
is to tell me and the american people of
the million people you've apprehended
how many of them have been released into
the united states
how many of them do you test what's the
positive rate
what's the system in place to test
people before they're released into the
united states
tom homan is the former acting director
of ice and a fox news contributor tom
take a listen to
congressman cuellar he was on fox and
friends he represents this area he's a
democrat
watch in the valley there were
70 agents that have tested positive in
the laredo area another 15.
it's not only the agents but it's also
their families when they go home
so we have to prioritize our men and
women of homeland and we have to
prioritize definitely
the border communities and the a local
sergeant there in la jolla said they
didn't know they weren't told
that this was happening in their
communities tom
well representative cuellar is a patriot
you know he he put politics aside and
he's telling american people the truth
and he's right you know and thank god
for asking this question i appreciate it
because over 20 barbecue agents
over 20 cbp agents have died from covet
and
in the line of duty deaths and and it's
not just covert it's tb
you know they take these measles and
chickenpox take it home to their
families so
barbecue ladies are in a tough spot and
and
as far as the previous from uh senator
graham
i can answer some of the questions the
the dhs said
they gave a number 55 000 released in
order to report
re to ice actually 166
000 aliens have been released in united
states and it's actually
over 63 000 that have released and said
well
we'll leave it up to you to report the
ice and and very few of them are
reporting nice
out of the 102 000 released with nga's
knowledge to appears to go to court
very few of them are showing the court
that's the numbers
the numbers right now yes one yesterday
one thousand
illegal aliens were arrested on the
border right now border patrol had
i mean a thousand yesterday were
released with a notice to report
ice a thousand just yesterday they
arrested seven thousand illegal aliens
just in one day yesterday
their 800 children were arrested
yesterday there's 14 000 in custody of
borbatro right now
that's the numbers that the dhs is
trying to hide from the american people
well we're reporting that they're
effectively releasing covet positive
migrants into the united states and
uh without any bearing on them to show
up for a court date
or uh a medical checkup or anything
uh here's the la jolla texas sergeant
down there just listen to this tom
roll it guys call 4-2 it reads like no
call 4-2
we did not know this no one told the
city of la jolla
no one told the police department these
people were here and no one told us
these people were possibly ill
apparently there's a group of families
that were gathered at a local restaurant
tom if you're covet positive you can't
fly here from london
england but if you're covet positive you
can walk into the united states of
america
across the southwestern border
well yeah look it's ridiculous because
the northern border is still close to
colvin
i mean they're asking mayors can
americans citizens to mask up again
and go door-to-door and vaccination
checks but the southern border is wide
open
out of that 166 000 that's been released
so far under president biden
how many how many of them are positive
covey we know we know for a fact dhs has
released hundreds of people with
covenant cases we know that borbacho's
not testing it 95
on the border there is no testing by the
federal government so
covenant cases are coming across that
border ice alone has
had over seventy five hundred probably
covered cases run through their system
right now today they have over twelve
hundred positive cases in custody
that came across that border and let's
remember ice gets a very small
percentage of illegal aliens crossing
that border
ninety-five percent are released so if
ice has 1200 in custody
how many been released with positive
cases it is it is incompetence at the
highest level well
still though the federal government will
tell you that you you need a vaccine
otherwise you can't work there
and and what are they going to say
tomorrow from the from the
commander-in-chief or waiting to hear on
that
and you can't go to a classroom in
america in
august or september unless you're
wearing a mask all this stuff is well
upside down
tom thank you for your time tom holman
will check in again